are you going to watch are you going to
watch like the u.s open will you sit
there and watch it yes
yes okay you're not a golf fan i will be
i said yes
yeah sure sure you did
best non-quarterbacks in the afc west go
ahead you take the first pick
wow okay i think uh this this to me i
think is
is it's between three guys on the chiefs
i don't know which one to take here this
is where i'm stuck i'm gonna go with
tyree kill
i'm going tyree kill here yeah because i
still think he's the most dangerous
or certainly in the conversation for the
most dangerous weapon at all of football
i mean he's a game plan changer come on
we know that
i mean defenses are 70 yards back
because of tyreek hill
and the kansas city chiefs and what they
do there so i'm going to go with tyrek
to lead it off
i'll go travis kelsey i know that's one
of the other ones you're thinking i know
it's hill or it's kelsey yeah callie
famer all right
incredible run incredible player and uh
incredible leader on that team great
compliment to patrick mahomes
uh yeah i mean it's a lot look there's a
lot of great players in the afc west
it just so happens a lot of them happen
to play for the chiefs it's it's uh
i think a little bit more of a a little
more apparent than i even realized once
i started to write now and write down
names for this i mean
i'm sorry but i'm i'm going chris jones
next
i i don't know maybe this is why kansas
city is really good
yeah i mean but chris jones for my money
is the best defensive player
in the division i mean arguably other
than aaron donald i could
say chris jones this might be the best
even as a lineman in football so
i gotta go there he's just too damn good
and i mean he's so good
that they're going hey now you're
dominate defense end you we're
dominating d tackle go to defense and
dominate there
so yeah i gotta go now that we've paid
you now that we've paid you as a high on
defensive attack we'll go play
defensively right
uh and trust me trust me if he plays
defensive end and plays well there's
going to be a renegotiation coming as
there should be for chris jones
we talked about joey bosa last segment
27 million a year look he hasn't been
as healthy as i would like but that
applies to pretty much
half of the chargers roster over the
past few years right but joey bose is
incredible
yeah i thought you'd be torn between
jones and bosa so
you take jones i'll take both yeah it
was i mean i think it's between those
two like what you're talking about
i gave jones the advantage just because
bozo was a little banged up last year
and those issues so that
that's really what was the tie breaker
for me but i hear you're there
um all right i think i'm gonna go with
my first raider here i'm gonna go with
darren waller next
darren waller other than travis kelsey
and george kittle i i think it's pretty
safe to say
he's top three-ish in football at the
position
man i mean big rangy can beat you with
speed
you know got a little physicality with
the ball in his hands and things like
that
he is without question arrived as one of
the top tight ends in football
one of the things about the nfl you get
injured you're gone
you're forgotten quickly and von miller
last year
i mean it happens to everybody ben
roethlisberger out of sight out of mind
2008 tom brady out of sight out of mind
the game keeps going
we can't forget that von miller is still
one of the premier
pass rushers in the nfl despite the
injuries
of the injury the ankle that that wiped
out all of his 20 20 seasons so
i'm not going to sleep on vaughn miller
uh he's still one of the best guys in
all of football and one of the best
players in his division yeah i
agreed i i'm expecting big things from
him and his you know dynamic duo buddy
and bradley chubb this year because
i think he's right there with him as as
far as close to being that
that kind of guy and uh i'm with you i
hope von miller tears it up this year
and kicks some butt
uh you know it's funny him derwin james
right they're two of the better
defensive players in football
didn't play last year along with bosa
who you know barely played
um man
i'm going back to chiefsville
i am i'm going to orlando brown jr
orlando brown junior is one wow i know i
think he's one of the better tackles of
football i'm a sucker for these big
nasty
tackle guys i'm a sucker for him i love
him i love guys that can like
just they throw out one arm and the
defense and flies back 10 yards and
you know the pass rusher thinks he's got
the edge on him and they get pushed 15
yards down in the field by one little
shove by these guys
overpowering in the run game and really
damn good
at pass protecting i'm going orlando
brown jr
you know at some point you got to
consider a running back i know
there's only one i think yeah but
i'm going to skip that for now i'm going
to skip that for now i'm going to go
keenan allen we got to give keenan allen
yeah okay
you know we talked about underrated
receiving duos
at some point not that long ago keenan
allen and mike williams i think fit that
bill
uh i don't know what it is but those
keenan allen has never gotten the the
appreciation that i think he deserves
but he's just reliable he's consistent
he gets it done
and uh that's my next picture yeah no i
think you're
i mean he does he's underappreciated he
is you know he's a route runner who
knows how to play
consistent super dependable but lacks
like the big highlight type plays and i
think
because of that people you know forget
about him at times so
good pick by you uh no doubt he's
underrated
man all right no no disrespect to tyron
matthew who i really love
that's my next pick all right i'm going
to go justin down for tyrone
yeah i'm going justin simmons first i
mean there's a reason
he's the highest paid safety in football
i mean he's the real deal he's in the
prime of his career
you know he's rangy as hell in the pass
game and for a skinny rangier type of
guy
he's a phenomenal tackler in the open
field and everything like that so
justin simmons you know one of the more
you know uh
forgotten great safeties in football i
go with tyron matthew
he's still got a high degree of skills
they are diverse he's a guy who can move
around and do a lot of different things
he's a great
presence on a team he's a great leader
on a team he's a great example yeah to
anyone in or outside of football that's
going through any type of adversity he's
one of the more inspiring stories of the
nfl over the past decade
if not longer than that and uh he's
entering the last year of his deal with
the chiefs and
you know the chiefs dodged the bullet
because they were trying to get earl
thomas
i don't know that would have worked out
nearly as well as tyler and matthew
worked out definitely not chiefs
i know yeah so yes that was big time
you're right yeah so uh tyron matthew
rounds out my my pick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports